the Joe Rogan experience JAMA take him
down yeah Genki listen John easily could
be 240 pounds easily just go I think
what he's doing is just he's gonna clean
out light-heavyweight there's really no
one there forms then clean that out and
then go to heavy weight maybe he's in it
or maybe he just stays at light
heavyweight and just goes down as the
coat and just keeps beating him all the
time no yeah it's weird
DC wants that fight again at light
heavyweight Mike come on D does he do it
at least that heavy weight every weights
the way to go to need everything for DCC
gets past eBay which is a big if ya
realize like D sake DC connected with
that beautiful punch in the clinch but
steep a has had over a year to stew on
that it's been driving him [ __ ] don't
forget sand good thing I think it's good
days an animal I know I'm not worried
about that I think he's gonna be better
I think Ringwraiths an issue I don't
think so DC's been way more active but
ste pays a real veteran man he's a real
veteran and he's a humble dudes a
hard-ass he's not gonna come in there
with a lot of expectations on himself
he's just gonna do his best
I think I'm not worried at all about the
size up her fight for DC look if Donald
Cerrone was taking a year-plus off and
then we're gonna fight for the title
block whoo
I'd like Donald to get a fight in god I
wish he would do that you and I are off
on this yeah I wish time it would take a
[ __ ] break and not fight Tony in
three days notice no I agree with that
too I wish he would take a break and not
fight Tony in three weeks notice but
three weeks after his last fight yeah
but when Donald fights a lot as long as
the best on reason it's the best Donald
that's what he wants yes he's just likes
to get in the groove he likes to stay
active I think for steep and be champion
and do that though mmm
name song who's done it go yeah name one
guy well everyone's different I'm not
going off measurements there's no data
live who's ever fought like the most
highest champion who's fought the most
the most like the most like active
active champion most icees pretty active
at light heavyweight heavyweight pretty
young I can act pretty [ __ ] active
and I think John is trying to be really
active I mean think about whole
divisions [ __ ] yeah he's gonna clean
sound though and dip out and leave them
like the [ __ ] queen of the Dragons
okay George st. Pierre fought 15 title
bouts Wow he had 15 title Wow
that's crazy realtor 15 how about Randy
kotor but that doesn't mean these years
later been fifteen over seven years
that's still all those years later Randy
Couture is still tied for the record of
the most title fights that's crazy
Mighty Mouse right under that with 14
Anderson 13 the difference is with all
those guys you know I mean it's all
different eras different division era
means everything because I think what
John's doing the current air is more
impressive Randy or George or any
Anderson did who do you think is a
danger to John right now there's no one
I'd like have you wait yeah no one
absolutely no one
Thiago Santos I know we got to hype and
I'm gonna go punch a chance to get for
sure I get that there's no one at light
heavyweight maybe maybe you know what
Johnny Walker but he's so far removed
right now he has to get by maybe three
more guys before we start me like I
might be a threat but he's attention
hope his shoulders okay mm-hmm if his
shoulders okay what that guy does is
crazy he starts his people he stopped
starts Khalil Roundtree with an elbow in
the clinch remember that yeah statius
that crazy this kind of eligibles one of
them bad boys vicious chaos him with
that and then chaos Misha Sarnoff with a
flying knee right to the [ __ ] chops
freak he's a freak but he hasn't done it
like John has to Shogun who to [ __ ]
you know ain't no comparison of Machida
look there's no comparison to anyone
who's ever fought in the light
heavyweight division and John Jones
right now there's no comparison there's
no threats
well except DC but DC lost he lost he's
not a threat at light heavyweight DC
Isis rat along every way I think he's a
threat right now not have you ate yes
have you ladies threatened his power
goes up we've seen how it works out for
DC but what if DC got more dedicated and
disciplined with his diet so what if DC
fights against ebay and says so when is
this deep a fight happen is it July July
okay so what if DC says ok August
September let's let's plan for New
Year's Eve with John Jones that weekend
and he takes a week off goes to [ __ ]
mardi gras whatever the [ __ ] wants to
do drink some drink some beer and
yeah have some pizza kicks back yeah
firm and then goes on a serious diet
with a real good nutritionist who's
gonna check his macros make sure he's
eating healthy food and you think that's
why he's not being John no but I'm
saying where he could get down to 205
healthy where he doesn't have any look
Daniel Cormier if there's anything has
ever held him back he's he's not the
best at his diet and with NTCC great
well he's one of the things that makes
him great he's a wrestler he's a
fantastic Russell that makes him great
he's a [ __ ] that makes him great he's
got his endurance is great incredible
ministry he knows that I don't know
about all that that's some people say
think about that think about the most
shredded guys in the UFC
oh I don't mean he should get shredded
what I mean is she'd he should make 205
with no problems where he could go to
war for five rounds with a guy like John
Jones without weakening him I don't know
if that's possible you might be right I
don't know if it's in his DNA
especially as a 40 years of age I think
a heavyweight his powers up and saw that
was steep a I think if he's gonna
connect what she has in the clinch
against John that powers there the the
the I still think he'll be an underdog
but it that that gap narrows that
heavyweight and that light heavyweight
it doesn't specially at his age I think
it it's even further apart now that
John's being more Act well maybe he
wants to do that to prove a point
because he beats John problem heavy well
yeah I'm light heavyweight a heavyweight
dude you're the champ John if you wants
to have that like C fight that rubber
match go even though he's tuned up go
there and let's see what happens if you
know now that I'm thinking about
especially for DC it's like DC dude if
you beat John at heavyweight and you
ride off in the sunset game set match
best of all time to ever do it right
like how about this Tito Ortiz right now
owns Chuck Liddell right Chuck Liddell
smashes him two times when they're in
their prime but then Tito knocked him
out and Chuck
looked terrible Tito K owed him it
looked really bad
and Chuck will never fight again and
Tito will always sleep at night knowing
he just [ __ ] Chuck Liddell up don't
just think about those other ones right
you know anything about it he got it
back he got it back in a big way TC we
got it back the way he wanted to lift
him with a right hand put his lights out
and then
a couple times when he's out and that's
a real play and forum for DC it's like
he even after the John loss he went on
that [ __ ] heavyweight knockout steep
a who some can argue it's the best UFC
heavy rail time he went on to beat Derek
Lewis who's so dangerous yeah
and then you unless they beat ste pay
for a second time what the [ __ ] you know
you know what I was really impressed
with
[Applause]